(energetic violin music)
(group applauds)
- [Man] (laughs)
- [Women] Whoo!
- He's a violinist.
- He's a freestyle rapper.
- And we took to the streets
of Los Angeles to serenade people
from the comfort of their homes
to help them get through lockdown.
- Yeah!
(bouncy beat)
- Let's chat to these lovely people here.
There's three of you plus the dog.
6 Feet, 6 feet.
Boom, nailing this.
We are going around and serenading people.
I'm gonna ask a few things
and then I'm also gonna rap about
that dog because it is spectacular.
What are your names?
- Oksana.
- Pasha.
- Colin.
- And Colin, thank you
Colin for, you know,
just keeping it right
down on the boring name.
- (laughs)
- What was your profession
before all this happened?
- I'm a model.
- Photographer.
- [Woman] (laughs)
- Colin, what do you do?
- I'm a fashion stylist.
- How am I doing?
- [Group] (laughs)
- So we're gonna serenade you.
Whichever song you wanna do,
basically, I'm happy with.
- The one with my solo?
- Yeah, let's do it.
(energetic violin music)
(cop car siren blares)
- [Man] Oh, perfect.
- The police have come.
I guess that's what happens
when you spit sick fire.
- [Man] (laughs)
- [Chris] Is that
because there's people in the parks?
- [Man] Yeah.
(energetic violin music)
- So we're gonna freestyle
for you guys, Oksana, Pasha,
Colin, Steele the husky.
Model coach, photographer,
fashion stylist.
♪ We start things off talking to Oksana ♪
♪ A model citizen ♪
♪ Say a real charmer ♪
♪ If you got a problem ♪
♪ Just waddle in to her office ♪
♪ She'll teach you how to modellin' ♪
♪ It doesn't matter if
you're nose is crook ♪
♪ Or if your ear has been pulled off ♪
♪ By a massive butcher's hook ♪
♪ She can say beauty is inside ♪
♪ All of the poses she
provides from the side ♪
♪ Maybe pop your hip ♪
♪ Put your chin in ♪
♪ That is basically how
you do the modeling ♪
♪ And then behind her ♪
♪ Right to the back there ♪
♪ He'll take the photos ♪
♪ He's name is Pasha ♪
♪ So passionate about
developing his film ♪
♪ He's like 'got to heat
it up in a dark room ♪
♪ Not a kiln ♪
♪ Otherwise you burn it ♪
♪ Put it on the big screen ♪
♪ Then Colin ♪
♪ A man who's so keen ♪
♪ To make sure everybody looking fly ♪
♪ Wearing a tank top ♪
♪ A real ripped guy ♪
♪ Wearing nice sweats, I'm
really really jealous ♪
♪ But then the main one ♪
♪ Man's best friend is ♪
♪ I see him ♪
♪ The face reveal ♪
♪ He a husky ♪
♪ And you know his name is Steele ♪
♪ He's so enthusiastic ♪
♪ He goes the whole hog ♪
♪ He will chase you down ♪
♪ 'Cause he's a vicious dog ♪
♪ I'm sure he's really friendly ♪
♪ And wouldn't bark at me ♪
♪ I could take him on the
leash to the park with me ♪
♪ He'd be running over there ♪
♪ And sitting back down ♪
♪ Saying Chris stop your rap ♪
♪ Shut it up right now ♪
- [Women] Whoo!
(group applauding)
- [Armando] That's when we
take a nice bow.
- [Chris] Thank you, thank you.
- Hey, thanks for watching the video.
If you're enjoying it so far,
please do like and subscribe.
More raps coming up now.
Were you the people shouting
anal and butt stuff?
- [Man] Probably.
- Okay.
- [Man] (laughs)
- If you wanna hit me with
four or five suggestions
and then we'll do this.
- Butt stuff, Kobe, Colorado.
- Lysol, Voltaire.
- You like Voltaire, you're
a French boy, aren't you?
So-
- Volt-aire you mean?
- Yeah, oh sorry - Volt-aire!
(enchanted violin music)
♪ French man with an arrogant air ♪
♪ Trying to correct my pronunciation ♪
♪ When I'm saying Voltaire ♪
♪ Ooh let me issue an apology ♪
♪ I didn't know about French philosophy ♪
♪ I think therefore I am ♪
♪ That's Descartes ♪
♪ You think you're very clever ♪
♪ You think you're very smart ♪
♪ But that's okay ♪
♪ It's not my fault there ♪
♪ Never halt ♪
♪ Never falter when it's Voltaire ♪
♪ I need some weed in the air ♪
♪ So I go to the Rocky
Mountains Colorado ♪
♪ You know the best state ♪
♪ Abbreviate to CO ♪
♪ If you're loving that 420 time ♪
♪ Just go right there ♪
♪ Better than CA ♪
♪ I allow ♪
♪ Switch that O for the A ♪
♪ That's a vowel ♪
♪ When you're up there ♪
♪ I will never trifle ♪
♪ You can visit Gunnison
Crested Butte or Rifle ♪
♪ All three cities when you go there ♪
♪ Obviously Mile High city called Denver ♪
♪ Are you from there? ♪
♪ Yeah you know me ♪
♪ I'm from Colorado ♪
♪ But now I love Kobe ♪
♪ Raeping him when I'm over here ♪
♪ Although your shirt says Pacers ♪
♪ Gotta make it up ♪
♪ Yeah you know I never plan there ♪
♪ I assume the Pacers
are coming from Indiana ♪
♪ But Kobe is on your shirt ♪
♪ I really gotta hand you ♪
♪ Best player, yeah ♪
♪ I call him Mamba ♪
♪ Sadly he passed away ♪
♪ We say RIP Kobe today ♪
♪ And then I move on ♪
♪ Yeah I'm up to snuff ♪
♪ I always use that lube ♪
♪ When I use butt stuff ♪
♪ I never ever wanna go in dry ♪
♪ I don't advise if you anal try ♪
♪ You gotta do it ♪
♪ It is not beginners' sport ♪
♪ You gotta do it properly ♪
♪ Like how you were taught ♪
♪ Always get consent ♪
♪ Never even linger ♪
♪ Always try and ease you
way in with the finger ♪
♪ If there's bacteria ♪
♪ If there's a virus ♪
♪ Just spray it on it ♪
♪ Yeah it elides us ♪
♪ It eludes ♪
♪ It moves away ♪
♪ You need Lysol with the
amount that I'm spitting today ♪
♪ Admittedly my saliva
could not you reach ♪
♪ 'Cause you're at safe distance of ♪
♪ About 24 feet ♪
- [Men] Yeah!
(men applauds)
- Good job.
- [Chris] Yes, yeah.
- Congratulations, man.
- Are the Pacers from
Indiana, is that right?
- They are from Indiana.
- Yes, British boy got basketball right.
- [Man] Look at you.
- That was great, guys.
You were fantastic.
You're the best white freestyle rapper
I've seen on the sidewalk today.
- Thank you very much for watching.
Make sure you like,
comment, subscribe.
(bell dings)
And also make sure
you check out Armando Violin Comedy
for the only violin stand-up
comedian in the world.
That is a fly and it is annoying.
- [Armando] (laughs)